[Music]
foreign
you're watching the Press preview on
Christmas Day a first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive over the
next half an hour we'll be seeing what's
making the headlines with the author and
broadcaster Bobby Friedman and the
contributing editor at Novara media Moya
Lothian McLean uh but first let's take
you through the front pages that we have
and we begin with the King it leads with
the king's Christmas message at praising
NHS workers and expressing concern for
people suffering with the cost of living
crisis
now that also dominates the front of the
express their headline king of caring
along with a full page image of the
royal family leaving church on Christmas
Day
as for the times it says that the King
used his first Christmas speech to
praise the selfless dedication of the
emergency services
King Charles emotional tribute to his
mother is the male's main story as he
became only the second Monarch to
deliver a televised Christmas message
well the sun has the headline the King
of Hearts alongside a photo of the
Princess of Wales outside church at
Sandringham
the telegraph says his majesty offered
sympathy to those battling to pay bills
the eye leads with the hundreds of
thousands of children waiting for up to
two years but by the NHS for key
developmental therapy
the guardian it says the number of State
home fathers who's left by a third since
the pandemic according to the office for
National statistics
and the star reports on a not so yappy
Christmas as a dog sets fire to a house
by jumping onto a bed and then
accidentally turning on a hair dryer bad
dog
just a reminder that by scanning the QR
code that you'll see on the screen
during the program you can check out the
front pages of the papers whilst
watching us of course and we are joined
tonight uh by the author and broadcaster
Bobby Friedman and the contributing
editor at Novato media Lothian McLean
guys lovely to see both of you really
hope that whatever you've been up to
today you've been enjoying yourselves um
but now you've got to what and Bobby
should we start with you um front of the
telegraph there are an awful lot of
stories about this uh kicking around
this morning but let's start with this
one his headline I feel for the families
who are struggling maybe making a point
there perhaps
yeah I think he definitely was so I mean
I have had the day off today fortunately
until now but I I guess the Royal PR
officers definitely have been at work
today because this feels like a really
different tone uh coming from uh the
king I still find a bit odd to to call
him that but coming from King Charles uh
quite different to the Queen's speeches
that we've all been used to over the
years now I think it was somewhat more
Progressive some might say and I think
what he was doing it was it was a really
not very subtle knobs to firstly the
cost of living crisis that's going on
and secondly to striking NHS workers I
think you it's important to bear in mind
that this was recorded on the 13th of
December that was at the the very time
when striking nurses were in this were
trying to get back into discussions with
government over their pay and I think
this will be seen as a bit of an of a
nod to that there was footage of
ambulances uh again in the middle of
ambulance strikes so it did feel like
this was a speech that did go that much
further and although the king did say on
his accession that he was going to not
be able to put forward the causes that
he had been used to be put been used to
put forward when he was Prince Charles I
still think we will see a slightly more
interventionist approach and I think
this is actually really quite
significant for the future of the
monarchy and this is the first step that
we're going to see to a a different
approach from the King compared to to
the queen
let's go to the front of the Daily
Express and I have to say this is this
is an interesting front page for me not
just because they go simply for the
headline and the photo itself which is a
really nice photo of the family their
headline um king of caring I mean at
times over the past week it has felt
that the papers like the Daily Express
have been slightly pushing the
government on the issue uh of you know
sorting out what's going on in the
public sector I mean the headline there
is using his first message to address
the great anxiety and hardship
experienced by many trying to pay their
bills and and keep their families fed
and warm I mean they're not sugarcoating
it
no and it's quite fascinating that paper
like the express which has
oh
with me I think perhaps have a slight
problem with you we can't hear you just
at the moment Maya speak for me and oh
no oh no we can hear you no sorry
to make and then it's nothing so carry
on I was silenced just as I was saying
that the express has historically been
quite anti-union and anti-strike so it
shows the level perhaps of discontent
with government in action and inability
to help bring an end to these strikes
and Source a pay deal something that was
really interesting about Charles's
speeches Bobby has pointed out is he
explicitly mentioned every public
service worker who does so much for the
country and you know Charles throughout
his entire career both as uh the son of
the queen and now as an obsession to the
throne itself has historically been
quite politically active he has been
involved in many causes he's often
caused perhaps a bit of discontent with
his involvement in political causes so
overtly as someone who's meant to be a
ceremonial figure and it's really
interesting now that he is getting this
unsubtherly involved in this public
dispute it's also worth noting that
recently Charles's foundations have been
donating huge amounts of money to
alleviating the cost of living crisis so
for example the cash that came from
consolation cards sent after the Queen's
death has all been donated to a field
charity which gives out prepayment
vouchers for um gas meters and energy
bills so we're once again as Bobby was
saying seeing the ACT involvement of the
king and it's a real departure to the
approach the queen took yeah it certain
certainly is I suppose uh Bobby as we
take a look at the front page of the
Daily Mirror obviously rather different
politics to the Daily Express but a
strikingly kind of similar tone uh being
struck there their headline Charles
praises the selfless NHS the question
has to be should the king because
clearly there is a political element to
the the message that he delivered today
clearly there is and I'm not going to
hear anyone say anything differently
about it should he be doing that given
the role that he has
well I I think he can do it just a
little bit he can do a bit of nudging uh
but I don't I don't think he can go too
much further than he has done I think
the the headlines from tomorrow's papers
bear this out because he has the ability
to win over the Daily Mirror and the
Daily Express how often do we see front
pages from the two of them on a
political issue uh which are in
agreement but that is what the the King
has done so I think this is uh
permissible just but I think it's also
permissible because his job is to
protect the future of the royal family
and I think one of the things that's
interesting is that you get a feeling
that Prince Charles almost wants the
support for the royal family uh and of
course I know it is widespread across
the side across Society but he he wants
it to maybe feel a little bit less uh
conservative
um and he wants to appeal to a slightly
broader set of people and I think that
this is where this gentle nudge is is
going it's trying to say the royal
family is not out of touch uh the royal
family does care about about people's
hardships and that's obviously a
potentially a difficult message for him
to have to get across but of course he
has great wealth and he's not someone
who's suffering from a cost of living
crisis at the moment but but I think it
was the the right tone because the
Royals do need to govern for the
entirety of it or to rule rather for the
entirety of the country and I think also
interesting uh in his speech was the
fact that he deliberately mentioned the
five major religions in this country
which is something I I don't think uh
Queen Elizabeth would have done in the
same way and I think this is Charles
seeing himself as the defender of faiths
rather than as the defender of the faith
and I think this is all part of a
deliberate strategy uh this is all
carefully thought out it's obviously not
something that just gets knocked up in
five minutes it's all part of of the
king trying to broaden the Royals appeal
and and to cement the Royals place in
society which I think uh can only be a
good thing so yes I know some people
might say he he should skip over certain
of those topics but I think he has got
the best interest of the royal family at
heart when he's been dealing with them
in his speech today take us to the front
of the times and again their headline
focusing uh on this being in their words
a gift for the tireless the tireless
health workers but I don't know what you
were doing this afternoon at three
o'clock I was watching Top Gun Maverick
I missed this speech but catching up on
it what a lot of people have been
picking up on including the times is who
wasn't mentioned Harry Megan Andrew
nothing for them it's hardly surprising
I'd have thought
uh well yes I mean this was Charles's
first speech as king it didn't make any
sense given the sort of scandal-filled
past two years the royal family has had
if he was to make a break with those
sort of negative headlines and as Bobby
said broaden the appeal of the royal
family Beyond this really sort of out of
touch institution that Towers over
Towers over the rest of the general
public with their massive amounts of
wealth Charles is trying to preserve the
royal family as Bobby has pointed out
and carry on that dynasty after the
much-loved Monarch who'd sort of held
this together for decades and decades
and decades is gone and with the Queen's
death so goes the power of nostalgia the
power of sort of the old institution
that she represented so it really does
not make sense for him in his first
address if he is going to undertake this
very delicate balancing exercise and
massive PR achievement to be focusing on
members of the royal family who have
either caused a headache for the
institution of monarchy or have caused
such a great Scandal that people have
suggested that perhaps we shouldn't have
a royal family altogether
um so I think again that's why he Focus
so much but also Charles really does is
a person who has always tried to balance
this line between his what he is which
is the you know hereditary Monarch who
is part of this massively influential
privileged Rich family and what he wants
to be which is sort of this very
philanthropic figure who people like and
it's very difficult to put those two
things together some like me would say
impossible so I don't think even if he
had the choice where he would want to
focus on members of his own family
because he has always been so invested
in that philanthropic angle as soon as
he has sort of more free Reign Over what
he got to say as king I think it makes
perfect sense they would focus on that
the prince's trust after all was founded
in 1970s because of his interest in
philanthropy and has just gone from
strength to strength since then and
Bobby we will perhaps return to the
front of the Daily Mail next door
because we just have to get to a break
but you guys stay exactly where you are
because at coming up afterwards we will
bring you this story on the front of the
Guardian their headline a Monumental
cultural shift with a third more
state-owned fathers will explain why
[Music]
welcome back to the Press preview Bobby
and Moya still with us taking you
through at the morning's papers um let's
start with you this time um the front of
the eye in fact the story appears in a
couple of the papers this morning the
NHS targets are to be swept away as as
part of the government's plans to reform
reform the Health Service explain
yeah so this is a story about a big
Government Review so I think uh Patricia
Hewitt former labor Health secretary is
currently working on a review of how NHS
care in England is administered and what
the eye is saying is that NHS targets
could be scrapped so that Health
Services instead run like a localized
school system some of the other
headlines that have come out of this is
such as waiting times uh for patients in
a e previously have said that within
four hours 95 percent of uh people
waiting in a e have to be seen that will
be taken down to about 75 percent uh
there's meant to be significantly fewer
targets because they're saying at the
moment these are tick book exercises
that take GPS and teens away from
delivering Frontline patient care so
what they want to do is look at how
recently integrated Care Systems are
working versus perhaps a more efficient
season efficient system because as we
know currently the NHS is is has
suffering from a huge backlog massive
delays in patient care thousands of
people are waiting this and ministers
think the problem here is that the NHS
is overly centralized
um whereas the individual trusts of
being forced to meet uh tailored targets
not no they're not they're being forced
to meet centralized targets rather than
tailored targets and they think if the
targets are tailored this will be more
efficient but that remains to be seen
just a word from you Bobby then on this
story I mean it's it's it's Rich enough
for the government to talk about getting
rid of targets at a time when they're
not hitting any of them
yes it does help doesn't it I think all
of us who are at work uh can't hit our
targets would very much like to suggest
that they don't exist anymore
um it's interesting though this is uh a
proposal that seems to be welcomed uh by
the chair of the Royal College of GPS
and it's it's a little bit the wrong way
around because Labor's proposals which
we heard from the shadow Health
secretary where streeting uh a week or
two ago uh were ones that got him into
hot water with GPS and their unions so
it's strange that it's the the other way
around between conservatives and and
labor but I think there's also a
particular political aspect to this this
review seems to be one that will be
carried out very quickly Patricia Hewitt
apparently is going to report as soon as
March and I think you can obviously see
that Rishi sunak has got an eye on the
next general election because the
government really needs to do something
to change the narrative and it needs
some big changes and big proposals and I
think this is part of that to at least
give the government to try and something
to try and hang its hat on when it comes
to the next selection to say look we are
trying to do something to sort out the
NHS because we all know there are
reasons for it with obviously with covid
most obviously and of course with uh the
financial problems that we have at the
moment there are reasons why things are
not working in the NHS but I think
everyone recognizes that they are not
working as they they should be so the
government needs to do something to try
and turn this around politically before
the next election at my front of the
Guardian their lead story absolutely
fascinating one this this cultural shift
Monumental uh in quotes there a third
more stay-at-home fathers why
yes so apparently during the pandemic
the amount of time that men were able to
spend at home with their children has
resulted in a huge increase in a number
of stay-at-home dads so it used to be
one in 14 dads were staying at home now
one in nine stay-at-home parents are
fathers and in the same period there saw
a decrease of 11 of the number of
stay-at-home moms so people are saying
that this is a Monumental shift in
gender equality I'm not completely
convinced it is because I'd love to see
specific data about how this relates to
parents having to swap the loads but
depending on how much child care costs
are
um impacting on their monthly income I
know right now we've had huge
discussions about how gender equality
would really be improved by the increase
of childhood benefits and increase of
child care
um support because that is the biggest
weight at the moment on gender equality
when it comes to Parenting and Bobby our
last story for this section of the press
preview is the front of the Daily Star
and we're going to bring this we're
going to bring this front page up if we
can guys because it's absolutely it's
it's this poor doggy explain this story
I mean I have to say I don't know if
this is posed by a model or not there
definitely looks to be some sadness on
his face
well I mean poor dog I would say poor
house owner I mean I I suppose this is a
fun Christmas story but it's not really
a fun Christmas story if you live in the
house which has been burned down uh by
the dog
um but
um The Daily Star reports that you need
to call k99 because an excited set the
house Ablaze by jumping and switching on
a hairdryer so clearly a very powerful
hair dryer better than the one uh that
we have a a home in my case but look um
I feel very sorry for people who've lost
their home at Christmas but I guess this
is uh in the papers today about as As
Good As It Gets yeah I mean he's gonna
be in the dog house you're going to say
oh come on it's Christmas day
um Bobby we will see you again for more
of the same in the next hour for now
thanks very much indeed